hello everyone I'm Christina Lynn and uh
welcome to the ybylc is the future of
the architecture so basically the idea
of this webinar will be talking about
what it is bring your own cloud
architecture and how we implement it in
red panda so kind of just to give you an
idea of what uh kind of what we're going
to go over today is kind of just going
to go over what is byoc and what the
difference deployments kind of
deployment situations out there and
probably the majority of time will be
going over the entire Architectural
Review of how things were separated and
how we take care of things internally
within our control plane and last but
not least I'll walk you through a
demonstration of how our clients can
actually connect to the pyoc environment
and kind of just show you how things are
things work practically in the users in
uh in user size kind of just with that
next is if we take a look at what
streaming services were provided today
you got two kinds of different
deployment options that that people
offer right the the first one is for
like the sale posted where people would
download the software and they would
then install the software on top of on
top of their own cloud or they were
installed it in their data centers and
they will manage the entire fleet of
clusters on their own so this is a very
traditional way of how we operate
um from the beginning of the time and
this is good but it kind of introduced
some of the drawbacks of the longer
laptop time because in order for a
company or a department to train a
person I really understand all the
things underneath the hood like how the
how your infrastructure needs to be laid
and how do you design your cluster to be
running can be long it takes longer for
people to understand things and also
there's constraints of resource you
gotta have to pre-plane pre-plan on the
number of clusters you need you probably
have to know what kind of CPUs or
Hardwares or this space say you want to
allocated to these clusters so there's a
longer time of planning therefore the
the time taken for you to actually get
things running will be a lot longer and
of course there's going to be
operational costs because the person
that you've trained needs to you know
this person needs to live you got to pay
for this person and of course this other
operating cost on
making sure that everything runs
correctly and you know setting up with
you know High availability costs and all
that kind of stuff needs to be justified
um but the benefit of this kind of um
deployment is that you get completely
control of access
so you control where everything is
deployed you control how many class how
many brokers in your clusters you can
control how your data is going to be
secured you can control the policy that
is applied on top of your
um on top of your how your system are
architected and everything and because
you know where everything is deployed
then you can kind of
um put all everything right next to the
workload so everything is closer so you
can to the network latencies is a lot
less comparing to the others and last
but not least a lot of the company
already have
um committed spend with a lot of cloud
providers so they can take advantage of
um of that of you know using the
promises resource that they were they
were going to use on top of the cloud so
these are the things that um
people kind of
like and don't like about the
traditional self-hosted version but then
because of the rapid you know software
development people wants to have a
quicker way of getting things up they
don't want to spend you know six months
or you know six months of planning and
getting people hired getting people
um trained on all everything so what
they do is they would ask vendors to
create a version or to to set up that
platform for them so this one is purely
hosted by the vendors the vendor is
going to set up the services they'll
provide a couple of endpoints they'll
give people like where they were
installed and then the services will be
up and running so the benefit of that
was in increase of flexibilities you
don't have to commit a lot of resource
in advance you can slowly add the
resource as needed you don't have to
have a dedicated SRE to understand what
the cluster is you have access to all
the experts since the vendor hosting
that services or the data streaming
services in this case has has been
running this for a long time so you get
access to the expert right away
um the problem with these kind of
deployment is the lack of transparency
and lack of control right because you
don't control everywhere everything is
deployed you don't control
um
you don't you don't see how they were
implemented you don't know how what's
going on underneath the hood because all
you see is a very is a class where you
don't see how everything was kind of
installed and how the policy was applied
in terms of security you don't know
where everything was hosted sometimes
they don't give you that so that also
introduced some kind of network latency
because you don't you don't know what
it's you don't know if it's as closer to
your workload or if it's kind of like an
ocean away from your workload so that's
kind of the things that people don't
people complain about when they're doing
a vendor Advantage um Services right
those kind of services on service
software as a service type of thing
right and then there could be a network
loophole if you're not connecting
everything correctly
um you might open up they on you might
open up unexpected connections then that
will introduce problems right so that is
why we said um
byoc has been really taken over in our
case a lot of our customers really like
this idea of bring your own cloud they
uh so there's a so we always know
there's a middle ground between you know
the self-hosted and the vendor hosted
version because this one is that we will
as a as a as a expert in running the
street data streaming platform class uh
uh platform we kind of just deposed
everything into a clients cloud
so what what clients see is that they
have completely access control over
things because it's deployed in their
Cloud environments the cluster is
running in their Cloud environment so
the data stays within the cloud of the
vendors so that they could get they get
to apply different policies in terms of
accessing the platforms and because the
vendors can deploy the uh so we get we
can deploy our uh our platform
um closer to the workload so you can
decide where you want everything to
deploy so you can introduce a lot less
Network latencies and I think one of the
most
um
people find intriguing especially with
the c-level conversation is that you can
use the committed spend because you
don't have to so you can have your own
discount in terms of talking to the
cloud device providers instead of going
through another layers
um by the vendors so uh but then you
also get the benefit of all the experts
that you have from um from the platform
so like from from the vendors or from us
right so we give you the expertise of
hey this is how you should install rep
and a cluster this is how you should
patch it and this is how the
infrastructure is going to look like so
you've got all that
um in terms of uh you know having that
running in the cloud environment so
that's really a very good I I think a
lot of our customers were looking into
this because they want to have the
freedom of controlling your own data
they want to have it all in the their in
their environment but they also don't
they also want to have access from the
expert they don't want to invest too
much in the beginning of hiring a lot of
experts running this this platform so
before we dive deep into the
architecture here's a quick overview of
what we what we talk about as a data
streaming platform so for the for those
of you who is already really know who is
really into the data streaming world you
probably know about Kafka right so red
panda is another C plus plus implemented
version of Kafka so basically what you
can what the clients can uh so basically
we are a replacement of Kafka um the the
client side doesn't have to know
anything but
um red panda can replace Kafka right
away because we are Kafka API
um compatible so the client can directly
talk to your webinar cluster but the
difference is that we choose to
implement in C plus plus and then for
everybody that you know C plus plus can
um have a lot better accessibilities of
you know managing and controlling the
lower layer of your computer CPUs and
memory so therefore we bypass a lot of
like jvm
um garbage collections where it's going
to take time to dump the Heap out as
well as controlling the thread so you
know like the contact switching in the
CPU can take a lot of time in nowadays
where we're going to avoid all of that
by controlling Threat by controlling all
the thread by constantly writing in
sequence and kind of kind of fits really
well with the you know the Kafka
mentalities of everything logs
sequentially right so you kind of just
put everything with the thread into
allocated memory and puts things
directly into the um into the storage
which is going to be either through an
me any storage where it's a lot faster
nowadays it's never the build the
blocking the bottleneck of you know
writing data into a storage place so
kind of that's how we see it today and
that's why people like most of our
customers loved using that and using it
to replace
um Kafka and um so that's kind of just a
quick overview of what we do so we are a
data streaming platform that provides
the Australian services for all the
clients so we we are very Cloud friendly
so we can deploy a lot of cloud
environment either with um dedicated
machines or we can deploy that on the
kubernetes environment as you can see um
so be right before we dive into the
architecture let's start with the first
pool what are you currently using to
stream your data
um using red panda are using mqtt Apache
Kafka call Fluid poster AWS in this case
or any other things
all right so for before we dive into the
architecture let's take a look at from
the post from our customers lens so the
way that we wanted to build is to make
it as simple as possible for our users
so to make it as easy as it can be for
them to have a very smooth adoption of
the streaming platform in their own
environment so what they need to do
first we give them three steps that's
all they need to do first of all they
need to provision their appropriate
access credentials so we'll have to
they'll have to give us they'll have to
create a not give us but have a
credential that um
allows creation of ekis creations of
setting up networks setting up storages
and all that you know there's a there's
a more detailed configurations that's in
our documentations but basically this is
all the infrastructure rights that we
need to have in order to set up that
infrastructure but all this are not sure
with red panda we don't keep that so
this one is for the user to create but
they also keep that in on their own
environments once they have everything
set up all they need to do is go into
red panda cloud and sign up for a
account right so we know that your your
you are a customer with us and then what
the customer needs to do is to think
about a couple of things right the
throughput the throughput is the um it's
kind of how we size our clusters uh we
tend to be very efficient on using the
resource so we don't need a lot compared
to a traditional coffee employment um
but if you think about it we want to
know how much you're expecting how much
throughput the bigger the throughput the
more broker your need and more the more
internal traffics that's going to have
within if if you think about data
streaming right and the second thing is
you need to give us your protocol
providers of course we need to know that
as well because that also determines on
the infrastructures of what command that
we need to give in order to install your
infrastructure and then the third one
that we will ask you about the customer
is what is your connection type is it
publicly available or is it internally
used only so this will use this to
configure the networkings so do we need
to install internet gateway or net
Gateway you know for Instagram or access
or do you want to isolate it within a
virtual private connection so everything
needs to be connected
configured in order to connect
internally another thing is for your
workload is going to be so this is going
to contribute to your network latency so
you want it to be closer to your
workload as closer to your workload as
possible so therefore we're going to ask
you about regions and also availability
zones this will contribute to the high
high availability strategies that you
want to determine right so if you have
more availability zones that your full
tolerance will be higher but again
because it's across AZ so there's going
to be a certain cost or a certain type
of cost of transferring data between
everybody's zone so it's going to be a
little bit slower but it's but then it's
more fault tolerance so depending on
what you need we can all cope with that
but in default what we do is we will
even within the same availability
available zones we can use different
placement groups to ensure that all the
nodes are in different places
so they don't also when things go
through we'll still have that
availability for you as well so that's
something that we do underneath the hood
that we don't share with the customers
but it's all think about so once the um
the customer decide on all this all they
need to do is to kick off the deployment
and that's it they will have a cluster
running in their cloud
that's how simple it is and that's why
our customers love it and that's why we
think byoc is the future
but in order to get everything running
it's um you have to have a lot of nuts
and bolts built underneath the hood in
order to make it runs as smooth as
simple from the customer's point of view
and I'm just going to take you over some
of the things that we did during the
installation so first of all the
customer will need to obtain a red panda
ID from us from our Cloud environment so
basically what I need to do is they just
need to register and we'll give them an
ID
and they'll have to log into either the
AWS account or Google Cloud account
currently we we provide two Cloud
um as as to to Cloud for hosting their
clusters Google and AWS so they need to
log into that with their credential in
their environment so this is not share
with red panda and then what went up
what um what they need to do is to also
download a tooling called red panda
keeper which is a tool that uses to
administer install and do whatever with
prepend now this is a great this is the
tool set so basically what they need to
do is just download the tool and run a
command line using the byoc
functions underneath red panda keeper
and this rep panel keeper is going to
then kick off the deployment from
customers
um from customers uh environment and
then it is going to talk directly into
uh into the cloud environment of what
they have and then install something
called Agent
and this agent is also powered by
terraform is going to then set up all
the infrastructure need to run the
Clusters so it is going to first set up
the networkings
um so make sure that it's in the right
softness the right vpcs you know I'm
talking AWS service because I'm more
familiar with AWS but and then you also
have
um then we also have to think about the
storages so we'll spin up the storage
for that and then because we want to
make sure everything's flexible it's
easy to add another node and all that
from for the future purpose we'll
install everything on top of kubernetes
so and after that we'll then install the
red panda
um
cluster on in in the kubernetes cluster
along with another
um pretty useful tool which is
redpen.com so that is going to
um let users see what's going on inside
their cluster and this is an other small
artifacts and utilities on in in the
cluster as well but mainly the cluster
and the console and that's kind of what
happens when the users kick off the
environment and after that they get to
see their entire cluster running in
their environment
and when so this is kind of what happens
if um the customer wants to access and
take a look at what's going on inside
the cluster so basically what I need to
do is log into the cloud UI which is
hosted by redpanda and what happens is
red panda is going to show you where
everything is and then it's going inside
the red panda
um UI we we added a
we did something really clever so we
merge whatever is inside redpanda
console and we kind of just um then we
stream that information directly from
red panda console into the customer site
into the customer's computer so it's
coming from the browser is
it it's going into directly into
customer's browser instead of going
through webinar so we don't see anything
because inside the console we'll show
you how many topics you have how many
partitions you have and then in science
topics will show all the
um all those all the messages or the
events that streaming all the data that
I was streaming into the topics so we
don't want to know that um for a red
panda so everything is going directly
into the browser of yours through the
cloud you using the cloud UI login as
the single standard endpoints and then
it's going to show you what's going on
inside the cluster
and if we want to operate say if
something goes wrong or if there needs
to be an upgrade so so something that's
really cool about byoc is that um with
that the user decide when they want to
upgrade their clusters so it's not up to
us it's up to the users because
everybody operates into innocent in in
different pace right some of them were
in a slower Pace some of them were
faster so we want to make sure that they
they can upgrade on their own needs so
that's kind of why we did that and
so whenever this whenever the user
decided to upgrade their clusters what
they what happens is that the cloud
environment are Cloud control plane so
we kind of divided everything into two
different things the control plane was
is kind of like a control centers where
it's hosted by repanda we decide on the
things that can be upgraded which
versions you want to upgrade it to and
the data plane is where there's this
actual streaming platform is operating
which is serving its need of streaming
data into for different clients and
stuff like that so those are the two
different planes that we have and so
what happens if what if you want to
patch it so basically the the control
player is going to issue a command and
that is going to say hey um patch
um to the next version of the cluster so
and then it's going to break it down
into uh smaller tasks instead of like
doing a big patch it's going to break it
down to small tasks and we'll check all
the pack all the track all the all the
tasks and then the agent itself is going
to pull so instead of us sending
informations into
um into the agent the agent actually
pulls so you can do a reverse um in the
reverse directions of pulling the tasks
constantly pulling the task from the you
uh from the control plane into the data
plane so once the data plane sees the
command it's going to run the command
apply the changes and then you see
everything upgraded
um one at a time so that's kind of how
it works
and then
um the so that's that's how the command
line flows but we also collect some of
the data
um the publicly over metrics coming from
we don't see the actual data in the
thing where we kind of collect all the
red panda metrics showing partitions and
leaders and see things going those wrong
but that goes best gets sent back to
Cloud UI so we monitor the health of
your cluster making sure everything goes
those okay
so
the benefit of
going through what the benefit of this
design why we go through all this pain
of Designing it like this is because
first of all
by deploying it by deploying into
customers Cloud you get to decide
wherever you want to do you have more
visibilities you can it's closer to your
workload and if something is wrong with
the control plane something goes wrong
in red panda what happens is it's it's
not going to affect the actual data
plane of serving the services because
the agent is doing a pulling so if it
couldn't pull anything it probably means
that I don't have anything else to do so
the control plane kind of just keep
doing what it's supposed to do and if
the customer and then if it comes back
up it's gonna comes back up up and start
working again right and if the customer
ever don't want to work with reppana
anymore they can simply cut off the
connections between the two and then
still operates on their own so I mean so
that's the isolations of two planes and
making sure that the the two planes
operate independently kind of helps when
designing is this is kind of a big
concept for us when designing the uh the
byoc
um services and here is a quick view of
how our cluster components was deployed
so we have all that all our um or
Brokers and our our all Brokers deployed
in kubernetes right so because the
hardest part of running a streaming data
platform like all the other databases
and all the data related product is the
data we don't want to lose any of them
to keep them safe to keep them reliable
we want to make sure every so the
hardest thing is to keep the state you
could not simply spin up an informal
part and hoping that if something goes
wrong it's going to recover it is going
to be hard and it's going to take time
for it to recover if if it's informal so
we what we did is we did our staple set
making sure that if something goes wrong
with the Pod itself your persistent
volumes and everything I store
underneath and we can still operates so
and we have an operator that kind of
looks after all the services running on
top of the kubernetes and up changing
things in the currently the console is
also employed into kubernetes and
there's a bunch of smaller software
utilities that we kind of run on top of
that as well and we also connected
um we also offload some of the
historical data back to the S3 to take
take advantage of that cheaper cloud
storage so everything gets offloaded to
that that's kind of how we deploy our
clusters on top of the cloud so if you
think about a control plane our control
plane is um in order to actually serve
that you know that really independent
data playing there's a lot of things
that you need to take consider about
well the first thing is um different
versions because different customers
spin up their environment different
times and because we also allowed
um you know that a user to update
upgrade their services on their own like
decide on what the timing of that so it
is it is crucial for us to kind of
provide them and to understand like
where they are what kind of versions
they have and because there's just way
too many components in the
infrastructure side as well like moving
parts so we have to make sure that
everything that we release is a um a
certified one
so what happens inside our control plane
is whenever we did a when we were
developing new features and all that
kind of stuff it goes through proper CI
phase and all that is pretty simple
that's very um everybody does that and
when we get to the release Pipelines
we have a um we have verifications and
scans for everything such as the core
qualities container scans Library
dependencies skins and all that making
sure that it's all running so it's a
certified release
and with this certified release we'll
create a software build materials and
each certified build materials kind of
represents a a snapshot of how how this
one is verified and we'll use that for
for the user release so we know where
they are so when the user comes in and
when they were asking for a new versions
of um red panda running on on the cloud
itself
um so basically what happens is it's
going to pull from the certified Cloud
release and looking at what's the most
current release what we have and then
pull the s-bomb into the software of
materials into into our control plane
API and this one is going to take a look
at it and then store the username with
the s-bomb so we know
um how they were deployed and then what
happens that is we have a then we
replicate this using CDC so everything
uses kind of stored into a database then
we use a change data capture mechanism
to export all the events all the things
that's happening to a red panda cluster
into underneath hood
um the reason we do we're doing that is
because there's a lot more internet in
internal operations and so we want to
have multiple receivers or consumers of
these events and kind of react up on
their own but the most important one was
the um was the one that goes into the
workflow because the workflow is the
actual control of how we kind of wanted
to install and how we want to
um how we want to deploy or patching or
change anything
in the data plane as well so this one
kind of controls everything so once this
uh once this uh new s-bomb gets sent
into the workflow the workflow is going
to kick up a the waffle engine the
worker engine is going to kick off a new
workflow and that is going to break the
entire workflow into different tasks or
activities and then that gets spread
into our uh and then that gets picked up
by our agents and then agents gonna
apply that into the data plane so that
is what's happening in the control plane
and um
that's kind of um
what's going on in how do we deliver a
more secure and Control software Supply
in terms of that
and if you think about the workflow
right so when when the things goes into
the workflow the workflow engine is
actually uh it's we use temporal for our
workflow engine but we also built a
couple of different
um like interfacing like a proxy
interface in front of um the workflow
server in case that we in case that any
version change or any API change or
anything we use gipc
um Sr points
um as it's easier to convert that
address and all that um so our we have
an agent proxy that is going to be used
to talk to our our different customers
and whenever there's a new installations
or new patching or anything a new
customer coming they they will kick off
a new workflow
and each workflow will then deployed
what then be um so they're they will
create each workflow and each workflow
because the reason why we're using
workflow is that if you think about how
we deploy
um things into into our Cloud everything
is long running and there can be
problems right so if you're spinning up
a say a eks right sometimes it fails or
sometimes it just it takes a very long
time for it to feedback so that's why
this workflow is a staple workflow we
keep the long running we break down
things that we can if we will run things
in parallel if we can but there are some
things that were are dependent on each
other so that's why we need to create a
work of a code workflow kind of just
take over things and um
and we kind of and also taking care of
the complex environment as well so
that's what what we did there
um and then in the workflow we kind of
break things down by Nature it breaks
down into different workers and
different tasks and activities and then
it gets put into different cues and then
um so we will be able to track where
this customer is at each each customer
where they'll get their own cue and that
is going to connect to their agent and
all the cues will then show okay so why
we have this um your this person is at
creating the VPC stage and this person
got you the S3 this person's got you
know their stuff done and there well the
other ones we patching so we kind of
seize
um how everything works together and
that's how the workflow was done in our
environment
uh so for zero trust access so this is
for this is in the situations if we want
to break the class
right like there's a lot of times when
we needed to access if something goes
wrong unfortunately hopefully nothing
goes wrong but if there's still some
things go through and we want to make
sure that we follow the zero trust
access mechanic mechanism where
everything needs to be authorized and
authenticated
externally internally whatever needs to
be authorized or authenticated through
dynamically so it's not it's an
aesthetic and it can only be valid for a
certain amount of time
so what happens if the red panda
Engineers wants to see what's going on
inside the cluster what the what happens
if they'll have to sign on the proxy
Services is going to go ahead and then
authenticate against this person and ask
for permissions from the customers and
the customer once they permission it
they'll receive a token to access the
content and then the prep handle
Engineers will then use that issue token
to access the environment and everything
is um it's it's and because this is a
reverse proxy so
um there's no going in it's just going
out so as well as authentication
Services uh auditing Services where
everything they do
um every single command they put in will
be tracked and recorded so
um we want to make sure everything is
100 secure we're not doing crazy things
for the customer but just helping them
to solve problems and that's kind of
what we did there
um the other the last the last thing
that we did for observability point of
view is the opposite abilities um for
this is absolutely um so the things that
we did for is kind of picking up two
things lock and metrics so we use the um
Prometheus to scrape all the things that
we did uh mostly seeing the balance if
all the all the Brokers are balanced
um if the leaders are balanced across
different places if there's um no leader
partitions however the petitions were
doing how many were assigned in
particular Brokers
um so these are the things that we look
for and the super the super rate at P99
agencies P95 agencies these are the
things I would look for in terms of
looking at the metrics and see if
something goes wrong we'll we'll know
and
um the other thing is we'll use um full
bit to collect data and that gets stream
thus gets collected
um from grafana low keys and then sent
to us in the uh and show in the grafana
dashboard so we have access to kind of
the log in the broker itself but not
everything else
so that's kind of what happens in the
data plane
um everything was all geared towards
providing a better services for byoc
secure mainly and automated and that's
kind of
what's going on inside the um the
control planes and this is what happens
in the data plane so data plane is
pretty simple and forward nice and
simple like similar to what you are
doing in a self-hosted version
so repanda will be deployed underneath
under in a VPC right in the virtual
program connection like it's it's gonna
be isolated in that
and so in order for you for the other
services to access
um the web Handler cluster
um you can either access it um if you
have already configured that as probably
accessible endpoints then you can access
it through the internet gateways and
because
um the the clients will be able to
access it through
um with the security some of the
security endpoints with ACL making sure
they create the credentials
um for the users everything will be
encrypted through TOS so everything's
secured in terms of services as internal
running internally with the same Cloud
um in a different VPC what you can do is
um you can use VPC peering I know
private link is coming up real soon so
that's why there's a different all these
different ways of connecting to the VPC
inside the red panda cluster other
things that you can do oops
other other
um way that I see people do it is using
through microservices as it's um so
they'll open up a microservices
um and then you remember so it's going
to do some kind of pre uh pre-processing
of the data and then that streams into
repanda clusters and then repennant
clusters just throw all the informations
back into the cloud storages or pass it
back to other services as well data
storage or data Lake whatever
um they were using so that's kind of the
things I saw
um or for the customer use case
um some of the different ways of how we
deploy
um our cluster is when you choose the
public accessible cluster
you will be the repent that will be
installed in the public subnet and
um and the red panda will be installed
in the same subnet as your agent
um so we don't have a lot of like
unexpected Network costs and all that
and repent out the the traffic skills in
between will be um in between the in
between the Brokers that's internal
repanda replication
um traffics as well as externally that
will be accessing through the endpoints
the clients and the VPC connections that
was appearing connections that you
peered towards different applications
outside so that's kind of why we did all
the all the listeners are protected
through authentications and
authorizations
um with the private cluster this one is
a little bit more complicated but I
think it's it's for the sake of making
sure that everything was secured so your
your Panda cluster will along with all
the connectors and the console itself
will be
um will be
um
stored will be deployed in a private
subnet so it will be it will be isolated
from your your agent and the agent the
agent will be in the public subnet
because it still needs to talk to the
external
um control plane so that's why you still
need we still need a public Subnet in
order for it to connect
um but uh just but we want to isolate
your cluster so that's why we have a
private and the public and that's kind
of the main difference between the two
so kind of depending on what the
customer wants and what they prefer and
this is kind of um how we did things
just to do a quick wrap uh recap on the
traffic that's going to happen inside
the entire cluster so we've got North
and South
um traffic so that's where the Kafka API
so that's actually the streaming what's
that's the actual streaming goes back
and forth between the cluster and the
client so that goes back and forth
that's the Northstar traffics and you go
you have the bootstrap traffic Square
it's the first initial call from the
client to ask for where all the Brokers
are you've got schema registry asking
for all the data format of of all the
topics that you offer like kind of what
what the data shape is like
um HD proxy if you don't want to use
Kafka protocol there you go you've got a
hdb
um protocol
um to put your events in or to retrieve
events and then we've also got you know
red panda class uh console where it's a
Google interface where you can show
everything also
um the Prometheus Matrix that goes out
um to um to our uh to to repent as well
so that's like the north south traffics
internally in between inside the um
uh the east to west Graphics that will
be mostly mostly the replication repanda
RPC you know how different petitions
need to be replicated across different
Brokers so they need to replicate things
um so that's where it most of the red
panda that would be mostly the weather
East and West traffic will be of course
then you've got some admin apis where if
you're gonna do admin stuff it's going
to be going through that traffic as well
um south to North control plane you need
to um where this is where the agent is
going to pull things from and then break
the glasses sometimes if we want to go
into the cluster and look at things for
you this is where the South and North
graphics and the other thing is download
the software after artifacts that's the
time when we want to upgrade and Patch
this is
um and this is where it's getting all
the informations from our s-bomb and
download all the right artifacts down
into your cluster right remember that's
kind of the south to North traffic just
a quick summary of Where everythings are
all right let's um go through the next
pool what are your biggest issues with
running a streaming data platform is it
the system complexity administrated
overhead performance concerns security
and compliance concerns or you don't
have just this running your data stream
data is super super easy I don't have
any problem with that
all right perfect
um
so I don't think I have a time to show
the entire full demo but I do want to
really quickly show you what's going on
um inside the cluster so I have a
I have a cluster that I spin up this is
a entirely byoc cluster so when you spin
up a byoc cluster this is kind of what
you see you see the Kafka API so this is
a bootstrap URL that you see where the
users is connecting to schema registry
and all that um things that you see from
the north south Graphics right
um
so this CL this cluster is actually
running in my cloud right so if you go
to I'm running everything in my AWS so
as I am the owner of this cluster I get
to see what's going on inside the
Clusters I get to decide on you know if
I see one of the ones or not all that
kind of stuff so this I own this Cloud I
see everything oops
I see everything that I need to run this
Cloud right so
and I can also see the different
um
vpcs that it created right so you know
um vpcs and all that kind of stuff it
created for me I can see the S3 bucket
you know the things that it's it's going
to dump all the historical data into it
it kind of just I can see everything
going what's going on because I am the
owner of the cloud and they were just
already in my cloud and I get to see The
Institute instance which is also running
the
the agent as well right the agent is
running here so I've got some agents
running
um sorry I have a bunch of stuff in my
here the old stuff but you get the ideas
you should just have one by the way one
agent is running inside and kind of
that's
um really simple and easy and then what
you can see here is I'm going to start
writing
sending data in there right so what
happens here is I go if I have
I have my own you know I have my own
python application that is running
inside this cluster right so it's in
this cluster it's in in a separate VPC
so what happens is I have a VPC peering
created
appearing connection so I can start
writing informations from my I can start
putting informations in my cloud I'm
gonna start
I'm going to start that applications by
turning it on
and then it's going to
start pumping informations into the into
my
into my cloud environment and if you
look at the topics here
you'll see I'm it's starting to stream
data into here and this is the console
that I'm talking about so I'm logging to
Cloud I'm logging into
redpan.cloud but what's the the funny
thing is this and all this information
was directly coming from my cloud
instead of going through red panda
coming back so we did something really
smart here where we kind of just inject
that the console into into the browser
here
so I can see what's going on what's
coming into into my cloud environment
it's coming here I can see the data is
coming in so I'm gonna I'm going to
start another
so this is what happens I have a repen
wlc clusters running I have a um a
cluster that's here that is going that
is sending data into the VPC peering and
I am going to
um we're on the caucus app where this
app is going to start
um reading information
from my cloud and what you can see here
is now it's picking up data
um from here you get to see uh big
things I have consumer groups where my
consumer groups are now consuming things
um from my uh
so you've got caucus receiver and I
think this one probably this one I'm not
sure this one is um is my clients so all
right so I think I that's I think that's
all the time I have
um that means quickly switch back
do a quick wrap um the reason why we did
you know bring your own cloud is that
it's private so your data never leaves
the cloud customer loved it
um I don't know if you heard about this
data sovereignty issues that people were
having you had a lot of regulations that
regulates people from where their data
is needs to be located so and then that
privacy preserve interactive experiences
right so and then what people like about
the what people like about is that it is
hassle free right the user only see
three steps and they have a running data
platform and and
last but not least I think appears to a
lot of the ctOS that is the c-level
users is that this is going to cost a
lot less compared to Kafka because we're
just a lot more efficient and you get to
use the you get the maximize your
committee spend with the cloud providers
um that is that's I that's it um you
know what I think that's open up for
the Q A's do we have any q and A's
hi Christina yeah we have um a few
questions uh the first one is is byoc
more or less expensive than dedicated
um it it depends um so for the dedicated
you get to kind of um work with the
vendors and see how they were charging
you but for the byoc I would assume it
will be a lot less because um well not a
lot less it's gonna be less because you
control the budget you kind of control
the hosting size and how you're gonna
negotiate with your providers so the
better negotiation you can do with the
cloud providers the less you spend so I
assume it's it's all really up to you
and kind of how you negotiate the price
and deploy and plan your budget around
things
awesome and then uh here's another
question are there any use cases where
byoc isn't a good idea
is that a good idea um well I mean byoc
is it's just another way of managing
your your Club your streaming platform
so I don't think there's a bad case
around it really because it's from the
customer perspective so I'm a client I
use I used to write a lot of
applications that talks to a Kafka or
webpanda cluster for me it doesn't
really matter I can just whether it's
operated whatever I can just use it I
guess from A administrative perspective
if you already have a bigger team you
have hundreds of clusters running in
your environment maybe that's the best
case where you want to do it on your own
otherwise I think byoc is a very nice
um intro gateway to intro and medium
intermediate users where they don't want
to have a lot of user a lot of training
people they don't this they don't spend
a lot of time operating that so it's
just different types of things right so
yeah
awesome thank you so much um and if
there are no other questions
um we can just go ahead and wrap up
um so thank you so much Christina for
your time today and thank you everyone
for joining us as a reminder this
recording will be on the Linux
foundation's YouTube page later today we
hope you join us for web for future
webinars have a wonderful day